all right next an incredible story about
how even the most difficult times can
bring out incredible good in people it's
about two college kids who came together
to help families a world away the
washington post reports that harvard
students avi schiffman and marco
burstein join forces to build a website
in just three days to help ukrainian
refugees and find places to live it's
called ukrainian take shelter and it
functions kind of like airbnb if you
have a house apartment a room even a
couch to share you can post it it
doesn't matter where you live people are
offering spaces in poland romania canada
the us with some hosts even offering to
cover airfare to get them there and
refugees can come with pets uh some have
you know their pets with them avi and
marco built this site to operate in many
languages also which is so clever polish
ukrainian czech and english it's so
usable they set it up literally within
days and for more information on this
you can go to our website at the
drewberrymore show.com to get
information on that
and
it's so good
it's good you know of course there are
really tough things going on
we all know that but there are moments
like this things like this that remind
me remind us all of the good that comes
out of this of about human decency and
kindness and coming together so well
done you too yeah those boys just have
my heart i saw that story and i just
wanted to relay it as soon as possible
yeah i love it
well next up we've got an incredible
story about two single moms joining
forces to buy their own home listen to
this in her essay on insider single mom
holly harper shares the story that she
and her friend herron hopper another
single mom were divorced and looking for
some housing stability and they couldn't
do it alone so they formed a partnership
and bought the perfect multi-unit home
together then they rented out the
additional units to two more women so
now the house includes okay ready five
kids three dogs two hamsters and a gecko
and they say this built-in community has
been great for the kids because they
meet a ton
of neighborhood people a lot of support
with child care car pools dog walking
this is another story about people
coming together when you just need
humankind to take care of one another i
mean as someone who became a single mom
this story
just really spoke to me i was desperate
for community i moved from los angeles
to new york
um i felt very alone uh and
i i think i've always made jokes with my
friends about like one day shouldn't we
just all live on a commune anyway yeah
come on i think safety is in numbers
i think this is such a brilliant story i
kind of hope that it's a spark that
ignites a movement i am so moved by this
story and it shows that you can define
what your family is right there's no
mold to fit and if we can take care of
each other in any way possible we should
do it i just i'm wondering how many
bathrooms are in this house because
there are a lot of people there that's a
good point ross thank you so much
[Music]